i take full responsibility
it's not my fault that it came here it's
china's fault and you know what it's not
joe's fault that it came here either
it's china's fault they kept it from
going into the rest of china for the
most part
but they didn't keep it from coming out
to the world including europe and
ourselves
what i would say is i'm going to shut
down the virus not the country
it's his ineptitude that caused the
violence caused the country to have to
shut down in large part
why businesses have gone under why
schools are closed why so many people
have lost their
living and why they're concerned those
other concerns are real that's why
he should have been instead of in a sand
trap in his golf course he should have
been negotiating
with nancy pelosi and the rest of the
democrats and republicans about
what to do about the acts they were
passing for billions of dollars to make
sure people had the capacity
i have not taken a penny from any
foreign source
ever in my life we learned that this
president
paid 50 times the tax in china has a
secret bank account
with china does business in china
and in fact is talking about me taking
money
i've not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever ever number one number two
this is a president i have released all
of my tax returns
22 years go look at them 22 years of my
tax return
you have not released the single
solitary year of your tax return
what are you hiding why are you
unwilling president trump your response
first of all
i called my accountants underwrote it
i'm going to release them as soon as we
can i want to do it
and it'll show how successful how great
this company is but
much more importantly than that people
were saying 750
i asked them a week ago i said what did
i pay
they said sir you prepaid tens of
millions of dollars i prepaid my tax
tens over the last number of years tens
of millions of dollars i prepaid
nobody has done more for the black
community
than donald trump and if you look with
the exception
of abraham lincoln possible exception
but the exception of abraham lincoln
nobody has done what i've done i am the
least
racist person i can't even see the
audience because it's so dark
but i don't care who's in the audience
i'm the least racist person
in this room okay vice president biden
let me ask you
very quickly and then i have a follow-up
question for you abraham lincoln here is
one of the most racist presidents we've
had in modern history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one he started
off his campaign coming down the
escalator saying he's getting rid of
those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse across the board
he says to them about the poor boys last
time we were on
stage here he said i told him to stand
down and stand ready
come on this guy is a dog whistle about
as big as a foghorn
mr president your administration
separated children from their parents at
the border at least
four thousand kids you've since reversed
your zero tolerance policy
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited plan to reunite the kids
yes we're working on it very we're
trying very hard
but a lot of these kids come out without
the parents they come over through
cartels and through coyotes and through
gangs
these 500 plus kids came with
parents they separated them at the
border
to make it a disincentive to come to
begin with
they real tough we're really strong and
guess what
they cannot it's not coyotes didn't
bring them over their parents
were with them they got separated from
their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
let me ask you a friend they did it we
changed the policy your response they
did
it we did not they built the cages they
who built the cages let's talk about who
built the cages let's talk about what
we're talking about
what happened parents were ripped their
kids were ripped from their arms
and separated and now they cannot find
over 500
sets of those parents and those kids are
alone
nowhere to go nowhere to go it's
criminal
it's criminal no one should be going to
jail because they have a drug
problem they should be going to
rehabilitation not to jail
we should fundamentally change the
system and that's what i'm going to do
but why didn't he do it four years ago
why didn't you do that
four years ago even less than that why
didn't i when you were vice president
you keep talking about all these things
you're gonna do and you're gonna do this
but you were there just a short time ago
and you guys did nothing
we did you know joe i i ran because of
you i ran because of barack obama
because you did a poor job if i thought
you did a good job i would have never
run
i would have never run i ran because of
you i'm looking at you now you're a
politician
i ran because of you all right vice
president biden your response to that
and then i do have some questions for
both of you
i'll tell you what i uh i hope he does
look at me because what's happening here
is
you know who i am you know who he is
you know his character you know my
character you know our reputations for
honor and telling the truth
i am anxious to have this race i am
anxious to see this
take place i am the character of the
country is on the ballot
our character is on the ballot look at
us closely we have to make
a country totally successful as it was
prior to the plague coming in from china
now we're rebuilding it and we're doing
record numbers 11.4 million
jobs in a short period of time etc
success is going to bring us together
we are on the road to success but i'm
cutting taxes
and he wants to raise everybody's taxes
and he wants to put new regulations on
everything
he will kill it if he gets in you will
have a depression the likes of which
you've never seen
i'm an american president i represent
all of you whether you voted for me or
against me
and i'm going to make sure that you're
represented i'm going to give you hope
we're going to move we're going to
choose science over fiction
we're going to choose hope over fear
we're going to choose to move forward
because we have enormous
opportunities what is on the ballot here
is the character of this country
decency honor respect treating people
with dignity
making sure that everyone has an even
chance and i'm going to make sure you
get that
you haven't been getting it the last
four years
thank you